hi slugs today's episode is very very
very complicated for everybody um please
come see me i'm on the road san
francisco portland new york city those
are all on sale now go to esteronice.com
and my new sleepover by esther uh set is
available check it out
sleepoverbyaster.com hello sluggies i am
coming your way bring all of your
insanies and your stannies
um to denver colorado the comedy works
on my favorite comedy clubs in the world
october 14th through 16th then i'm at
laugh out loud comedy club in san
antonio october 22nd through 23rd i'm at
skankfest in houston texas november 5th
through 7th i'm in plano texas at the
house of comedy uh november 11th through
14th the irvine improv december 2nd
cap city comedy club in austin texas
december 9th through 11th bananas comedy
club december 16th through 18th
and then i'm going into january so
there's a lot of dates go to my website
andyletterman.com shows and you can
catch me there come out we've been
having the best time ever
[Music]
jessica is that where you're from new
york i grew up in jersey i'm like a real
jersey jew i'm kind of scared of you
i only yeah i feel like jersey girls
like beat me up oh no i am from an artsy
my mother's an art therapist i grew up
in like a very hippy like okay cool
every kind of person
no i am so not like
from jersey no it's not that's people
watch jersey shore and think that's
jersey yeah
also to be fair i actually think i put
my money on you to fight snooki really
from jersey shore yeah because you guys
are the same height but i feel like
you're i feel like i'm my nimbleness
will come she's a wimp
wait but she was on wwe
snooki yeah
was that her name she probably kept her
name her name
changed her name oh i mean her
wwe name was probably snooky
yeah
i i'm pretty sure she wasn't wwe i must
have dreamt it
um in some delirium but i'm pretty sure
she was it's really scary to me that you
know that and then not only that you
know that but it's so obscure that both
me and jessica are like what like
neither of us have even had like a
rumbling nobody yeah none of you guys
watched um wrestling when you were
younger
no but i'm older than you and also no i
i get it why you i'm a girl how dare you
esther look see
oh wow after i changed my mind i might
have my money on her i still think i
could fight her because i do think that
like my flexibility and my
grace what's about anger
i don't know if you should
how angry are you i think whoever's
angry or would then yeah she's pretty
enraged i think this yeah yeah you're
right you're totally right
so jessica you're
i'm gonna ask me anything i'm gonna say
the cheesiest [ __ ] ever right now no
don't okay here's the thing
you're a new york comic and i like know
nothing about that world and to me it's
just like so
like scary like dominated by men like do
you
is that like your do you is it scary i
feel like you you represent all the
things in the in life that i think are
scary you have four kids you are from
jersey and you have to hang around men
in comedy you're so cute
well i'm not in a typical typical
situation of a woman who has four kids
let's be honest because i have a wife at
home
okay so it's easier oh
so i'm not like these female comics who
gave birth
you know went on stage pregnant you know
what i mean i went through that because
that's different
and that they're like the primary mom
right who leaves their child like i'm
like i'm here with rachel feinstein you
know we made this prank album together
which you know i'll talk about but yeah
um and she left her baby and like she's
her mommy and like left her baby and
she's here like my wife is home with my
kids
my ex is home with my oldest and like so
they're taken care of and i go away and
then i know they're being taken care of
by their other moms so i'm in a very
good situation and so grateful right a
secret is just being gay right
you're only
uh you're sorry
she's way too happy no
i am like
i
we talk about it we every week we try to
figure out how esther truly feels about
that yeah i'm definitely on a weird
spectrum like all the young people today
she every episode she asks to stick her
fingers up my [ __ ] every episode but
like i do have i don't know why i just
thought that was so funny
because the way you said it was just so
matter-of-fact and because like yeah
yeah the only issue is i do have a male
fiancee
oh that's yeah that's kind of a little
all right so did you hear where you you
can ask me anything about when did you
know well you were gay this is taking a
look
great story about how i came out really
yeah it's an amazing story tell me now
okay i'll tell you when i was when my
friends were like i had little crushes
on boys when i was younger because i
think i
i mean i did i did have crushes um but
nothing major like my friends would like
die over boys and i was like yeah
you know i thought boys were cute i
always wanted to be with my girlfriends
and a very tight group of girls that
sounded bad they were all tight
um
all my friends were tight
and you know i used to fool around with
all my girlfriends growing up i was like
the town [ __ ] like i always you know
used to play with them like you'd make
out and touch each other whatever
um and i i would i would i i like they
all had boyfriends in high school and i
never did um
and i would just like kind of fool
around with guys because as we were
supposed to do but i had no idea i was
gay or
like into girls i all i cared about is
what people thought of me
that's all i cared about which seems
like probably that's how everyone right
and wanted to be liked wanted to be
popular and i was friends with everyone
and i was the class clown and that's all
i [ __ ] cared about
and so it wouldn't even
like occur to me
and plus when i was growing up
you know i'm older like you no one was
gay yeah you weren't gay
you were feminine or you were but no one
you know if a guy was like seriously a
third party this saturday you were like
he's feminine but no one said david's
gay
whoa it was not like that
at all so then i like you know in senior
year all my friends had boyfriends and
then i was just hanging out with them
and i had never had sex and then i went
to universe this is kind this is sad but
this is a this is a story and hopefully
it'll help someone that's watching or
listening because i really did this to
just like
prove to myself that i was you know
normal i don't want to say not gay
because i wasn't even aware at this
point but just at least normal and one
of the
one of the girls i went on my freshman
orientation from university of maryland
got completely wasted you know met a guy
very cute jewish guy from maryland and
just like had sex like i had never had
sex and lost my virginity in a room in a
hotel room with two other random people
and it was sad
i mean it was fine but it was like sad
like that's how i lost my virginity just
so that i would lose my virginity before
i went to college you know what's really
weird is that
is not a sad story to me but to me it's
very normal and like you know what i
know like most people i know really like
weird like nobody loses their virginity
and like the way like you want to i
think it's sad if you lose your
virginity to someone you love
that's sadder to me that's amazing
because it's something that i feel like
is going to get out the way
sexual exploration at any age and i tell
my niece this she's 19. yeah and i'm
like
i don't care get it out the way it's
like this sort of like burden that like
hovers over your head and you think it's
something that has to be special yeah
that creeps me
i'm supposed to feel passion and love
for someone to enter me and it's just
coitus no i get what you mean i think
what was i think what was sad was that
there were two other people in the room
and then i was wasted oh yeah and you
probably never
i'm an addict so that was like i didn't
know i was an addict then but i was
wasted so it was one of the things i did
when i was like in a blackout you know
what i'm saying so it was kind of did
you feel it after oh sure because i you
know bled and i mean it was i that's sad
right exactly
feeling sad yeah totally and then there
were these two other people that were in
the other room that i didn't know and i
didn't know him and it was just kind of
a weird why did i not bleed
maybe it was so thin your hymen that
just was like maybe you were humping
things from the age of four i truly
believe that no i'm like did you believe
yeah
i yes i did bleed what the [ __ ] it like
what's going on with me am i still a
virgin
that's
hilarious i have not what like whatever
anyway sorry
but you are a gymnast that is the
funniest question am i still a virgin
like
is this
i ended up going to college and
just drinking a lot and whatever and and
and [ __ ] guys and never a boyfriend
yeah just you know like would it be like
pleasurable to like did you
i never minded the actual [ __ ] the
having sex but i never wanted to spend
time with the guy after
like i would leave and i never wanted to
have a boyfriend yeah but the actual
having sex was fine with me yeah yeah
i say this on stage and i'm not saying
this is like a bit but it's really tr it
is a bit of mine but i really mean it i
like second dick because i'm an eater
so i like that feeling in the back of my
throat because i like [ __ ] my throat
with food i don't chew anymore
so i literally gag on food so i like
that like oh like that's the porn i
watch
i wa i put in face [ __ ] brutal i love
watching women podcast was almost going
to be called what skull [ __ ] no that's
amazing yes it was i would never be okay
with that i asked george you're like i
wouldn't have been a part of this
complete name was skull [ __ ] a faithful
podcast
because you like that too i love these
skulls
don't tell me that i'm never looking at
you again
i am a skull [ __ ] queen i like to gag so
hard don't even i'm never looking at you
again she is so it's like this is can
you never say that to me again
[Laughter]
dude she's the she cannot say that ever
again in my presence
that's the hottest thing to me oh it
is are you kidding i put in when i watch
porn on my phone on a daily basis
i put in face [ __ ] brutal
that's me i'm the porn you watch so i
yeah my wife does that to me i want to
leave that's what i have i shouldn't be
saying this honestly i honestly i don't
love having that done to me
i wear a strap i'm not kidding i'm i'm
the same it's like i can't you're so gay
yeah you're right that turns me on this
is interesting yeah you're the real deal
lesbian yeah i am so
now
well because you're s
okay because she's not right
she's so who would ever say she's not
hot
who on earth man or woman would not say
she's not hot reaction i mean what i'm
not gonna respond to that question
could you imagine looking at her and
being like uh whatever
she's all right
it's so chill i mean a blind person
you could literally just touch her and
go she's hot or a blind person
someone with no eyes
just sockets
could somehow think she's hot
that's literally the only acceptable
reaction
dinner the other day
we went to dinner and what did you say
across the table your poor fiance esther
was on edibles and we went to korean
dinner
that sounds like a tv show esther was on
edibles
she was on one side of the table there
were about eight people in between us
and then her fiance and she yells out
she's like dave will you have sex with
kalyla
and poor dave dave is like don't do this
to me right now
i there's like a few people in my life
where i'm like if they had sex with my
fiance like i would be
fine with it yeah you have to allow it
with her i mean yeah it's like yeah like
i just feel like i would be fine i mean
the whole thing the tattoo like the
whole thing is just insane i know i do
feel like i could really have like a
real gay person conversation with you
about how dissecting how hot kalila is
yeah but i don't want to do it in front
of her
no we can't do it in front i'm literally
assaulting her with my words right now
just gang bang it out guys i mean
it's not even the looks it's the energy
whatever let's get into my story so yeah
so
it is the energy it's the energy it's
literally i'm it's it's i'm feeling it
it's like a
comfort it's everything just tell me
i'll be okay
just kill me
just literally tell me i'll be okay like
[ __ ] kill me just stab me i just
oh my god all right so okay go go
so
this is such a great story you'll love
this so i joined a jewish sorority it's
[ __ ] amazing and it's not like they
are in a sorority it's not like that
we're like stoners and [ __ ] don't
show up to anything and i live in a
house with 40 girls amazing because now
i'm like
at my university of maryland i'm in this
cool sorority these girls are great
and we are like the you know like the
[ __ ] ups we're not this is a great group
of women and girls and we're like
awesome friends and
you know
all the other sorority houses are like
really into it and we're like oh we
don't show up to anything we're drunk
all the time and high and it does seem
like a dream story oh it's [ __ ]
amazing
so that's where i went to school so
that's it's all houses so i live in this
house with 40 girls amazing right
and i'm the social chairman i'm the hell
master
okay so i like it is so awesome so i'm
like all this [ __ ] my senior year
this freshman walks into uh
to to rush which means she wants to
pledge
and she's jewish and she's stunning
we're still friends to this day and we
just saw each other it's crazy i'd never
been with a woman before i never
remember the girl and we just connected
and she was beautiful jewish girl from
jersey like me and i don't know what
happened we just like there was just
this energy
and
i'm a senior she's a freshman and we
just she ended up pledging for my
sorority and i again was like the pledge
head of the pledge whatever because i
[ __ ] with them and
and uh
we would just sit in my car and this is
so crazy but just stare at each other
for hours shut up
what yes
without even speaking were you like
smiling
on and off
this is like a k drama
it's amazing
and we wanted to be together
constantly oh i love that feeling and
nothing sexual but like i was obsessed
with her like i just and i had no idea
what was going on i know what was
feeling i didn't know why i was like
what is happening i know thought i was
gay whoa it was just her we were
constantly like wanting to spend time
together but then kind of like hiding
that and then i'm like why am i hiding
wanting to be with this girl all the
time like what is going on
and
we
ended up going home for christmas break
this was after months of doing this
and we were in my mom's house in my
attic in my room and we got we were
drinking wine and smoking pot and we
started wrestling
isn't this awesome oh my god is this can
this be a movie i know it's amazing
and then we started wrestling and then
we kissed
it was so hot
because it had been up for months
and just to think like i would i'm like
putting myself in your shoes and i feel
like i would be so nervous that she's
not feeling that at that point we knew
we were
like okay we were madly in love with
each other at that point it seems like
it i mean but there wasn't each other in
a car esther no worries hey kyla want to
get go
the corolla that you just drove down a
flight of stairs that one
esther just drove her corolla down a
flight of stairs
you care to tell jess about that story
as well why did you go downstairs in a
corolla i no one knows i don't know i'm
not even that kind of person
i'm not
i don't make it who's that kind of
person elderly you know people who like
lose their females and they like they're
hungover and they they accidentally
drive off a cliff that's not me
like it was oh hey baby hey
legs we got legs and cowboy boots hi
um and we're talking about two things so
many people
you're gay i'm in the male gaze [ __ ]
i'm telling them the coming out story
you missed some of it but i'm still in
it all right start it again
start the podcast over please
annie you work out a lot
that is so nice of you to say is almost
mocking me but i am starting to work out
a lot i am starting tomorrow and what do
you do when your muscles are so my
muscles i swore that time i did do uh
exercise over the pandemic i did use the
theragun and they did it did help you
guys don't let the stress of daily life
weigh on your body whether you're an
elite athlete or someone like me and
annie therogan can help theragan is a
handheld percussive therapy device that
releases your deepest muscle tension
using a scientifically calibrated combo
of of depth speed and power and it's as
quiet as an electric toothbrush
we like our vibrating things to be very
quiet so our boyfriends can't hear the
gen 4 theragun doesn't just feel good it
gets to the source of the pain by
releasing tension using theragan's
signature percussive therapy which goes
60 deeper than vibration alone i do like
that part about it is that you can sort
of adjust the settings because sometimes
it's too much it's like you don't want
to like yeah some people love that some
people like like deeper
well there's just some injuries that are
a little bit of a bruise too like you
don't want to go too hard in them and
for me when i do have those hard
workouts when i do like hit training and
stuff it just cuts my recovery in half
and it is a godsend for me yeah it's
like rolling doing a rolling out your
muscles faragun is trusted by 250
professional sports teams like real
madrid and elite athletes like paul
george deandre hopkins maria sharapova
hundreds of thousands of customers and
myself and annie
try theragon for 30 days starting at
only 199
go to therabody.com trash tuesday right
now and get your gen 4th air gun today
that's
therabody.com
trash tuesday
oh boy did i sleep well oh my god kala
tell me how tell me i felt like i was
sleeping like uh in the most comfortable
forest bed ever i i felt like i was on
vacation in my own home and was it
guilt-free it was guilt-free you know
why it's guilt-free tell me because it's
attitude oh attitude the dirty little
not so secret about the bedding aisle is
that while cotton might be the most
popular fabric for sheets duvets and
pillowcases it's also the most damaging
to our planet yes our planet our home
even organic cotton annie
it takes its toll that's why we are so
thrilled to introduce to you attitude
and the reason why annie has been
sleeping like a baby every night it's
made from naturally organic bamboo okay
bamboo i'm like a panda bear do you
understand that
attitude sheets are made without toxic
chemicals and use 500 times less water
than cotton plus they're silky soft
they're so soft they are they're so soft
they're so comfortable for you and the
environment unlike cotton which consumes
massive amounts of water energy and
chemicals during production attitude
uses naturally organic bamboo
the most resource efficient plant on the
planet try any attitude betting for 30
nights if you're not completely
satisfied return it for a full refund
right now you can get 20 off your order
plus free shipping when you visit
etitude.com
tuesday and enter promo code tuesday
remember that's attitude as in eco
attitude order today for free shipping
and 20 off your order at etitude.com
tuesday promo code tuesday
[Music]
well before we fit here give you a break
to before we tell your story jess
explain the going down the stairs with
your corolla
there's no explanation i feel like we
should save this for when we can really
watch the vid there's a video yes which
is viral there's no no there's there's
some photos i
i was a nice person and george asked me
to fill in for your niece at your
husband's podcast yes and your twin
brother's podcast yes yes bad for an
evil evil twin
and i did it and it was totally fine
whatever and when i left i was like
ready to get the [ __ ] out of there and i
drove down the stairs that's it and i i
so basically i thought it was an exit
yeah no it's such a better story that
you are trying to escape i thought now
that you put it in the under the guise
of your escaping bad friends it really
does paint a better picture
so okay so i thought it was an exit and
it i quickly realized oh my i was like
oh my god oh my god what's going on and
then i like try i didn't really
understand what's happening so i tried
to push it on the gas to just get the
[ __ ] out of there
and then i it was getting worse so i
stopped that and then i tried reversing
because when you do something
embarrassing like that you just want to
get out you're right anyone you know to
see you just want it to be over
and i just realized like oh i'm not my
car is stuck like this is so i just
immediately called george and was like
george i need you to come outside if
they come out if they come out before
you wanted them to would you maybe just
put your seat back
did it cross your mind that a tesla
would never have allowed that to happen
no i think a tesla would you don't think
it tells us
i'm actually i've become very anti-tesla
because of the stairs incident because
i'm like
i want a car i can just beat the [ __ ] up
and then throw it away if i need to now
we know why she needed a corolla annie
there was no other car she could have
had imagine you should do that to a
tesla i am surprised that you don't want
a car that drives you around it's like
pretty cool
you can do other things it could be you
could be packing your merch
in the back seat also i brought this if
you wanted to comb your pubes
i brought this for you it gets all ice
out
it gets the lights out what
annie i love you i missed i missed this
much so it's all clean
i love this isn't my one i love you i
can't take you at all i was i was gonna
try to squeeze into some leather pants
for you oh i love it last time i saw her
she was wearing leather pants i mean i
haven't seen you in a while yeah stood
outside of years she was staying at the
standard hotel which i don't even think
is open anymore it's not downtown or
yeah
across from the comments
why am i so concerned like who cares i'm
like oh my goodness
because we stood in that range yes wait
do you remember when some people we know
just laid there
oh yeah in the box of display we know
some girls i know that box you're
talking oh i bet you do
i should have brought you one of my eat
out masks i just
i know that box
we know you've gotten around yeah not
with comics okay so just to catch you to
speed we're just at the part of the
story where she is starting to make out
with a girl after wrestling after
wrestling after that
after months of just staring at each
other it's my first lover then what
happens
then we both made out like crazy and
then we freaked out and she left
really yeah and it was her house [ __ ]
just happened it was my mom's house
wait that's so that we were like what
just happened all right oh god i got
better go like it was crazy
yeah it was really freaked me out
freaked her out and then what did you
get then we went back to school and
drove together a week later and [ __ ]
forever
we went to school early and went to my
apartment and just like for a week just
like literally had sex it's gotta be so
much easier to lose your virginity to a
girl because you know your own body i
didn't lose my virginity you you missed
that part where i bled in front of
strangers um
i did that this week that doesn't have
to be
i did that in the desert on acid
you just gotta not bring enough tampons
that's all annie i love you i
i did that this weekend
oh that's right that was your big desert
then this tan [ __ ] there's a lot to
talk about this is the first thing i've
ever seen in my life it's getting border
and cold we're not allowed to talk about
her i don't know i don't even even even
look at you i can't handle it i'm not
looking at her it's a palpable um
sexual
tense oh yeah yeah and let's just say
when you said 10. esther
is killing me with this
listen i don't want to eat any of your
dirty boxes i'll watch though i'll hold
the camera they're not dirty
i believe you're clean i can't see her
she travels a lot so it might be dirty
but i don't even grow pubes anymore you
guys know this i know
she's like
my legs can go behind my head it's like
so irritating am i officially gay like
that
you're
amazing you are
she and i just had such a moment just
now that no one even
you're gay
you're [ __ ]
gay
thank you she's gay
i'm telling everyone right now i'm
saying it live on the podcast she's a
lesbian
at least
first of all she's at least bisexual
well you know from that moment i just
got it with her so crazy she's at least
bisexual night her with your clothes you
are you're bisexual i know
well that was that was a science just
what just happened in the eye when i
said this knight her with your [ __ ]
with mine knight her or bring a dildo oh
i'll knight her with with a dildo do you
guys bring strap-ons with you everywhere
yeah they're in my bag they're in the
car
they're in the lift i pulled a dildo out
instead of your mic
on stage
and they're like oh my god oh cheerfish
it's so hard to be a lesbian comic isn't
it could you imagine
could you imagine i just take out my
strap-on how's everyone doing oh my god
i dare you tonight hollywood improv
yeah on my shows my headline i'm coming
you are yeah i'm gonna come oh i'm so
glad it's gonna be funny and i'm just
gonna imagine is that so psycho and
people are like i think it's always a
dentist
like i'm gonna come see you you better
be good it's like can you i can't even
talk to you right now there's metal
that's every jewish show i do you're
gonna be funny
no [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we talk about the holocaust for 45
minutes
what happened with after the [ __ ] did
you guys officially get together did you
in years
seven years we were together three three
of them were a secret so that almost
killed me
because uh
we had a hide and lying meeting hotels
and it was a nightmare that was a lot me
because i cared so much for people
everybody
you didn't come out you weren't gay
everybody just thought you were poor
you're like oh they had to share the
same hotel room
everyone knew my college friends came to
my gig in jersey the other night you're
like they're like do you think no one
knew like you're such idiots yeah i feel
like college is really when you can tell
too the shoulders like there's a picture
of me where
i guess you have to come out as straight
in college is what i'm saying like
because my i there's a picture i'll try
to find it
my my
id
like it like squished me and then you
kind of get into exercise for the first
time in college
i was always wearing a sports bra like i
just looked like i like i i called [ __ ]
and we understand you what's this
lacrosse stick
they do look like [ __ ] by the way i
just i just need to say because i know
that my fiance listens to these to make
sure that nothing happens make sure
you're straight esther
esther
she touched me she went like this so
that was very straight it was like
straight to jerk my wrist that was one
of the funniest things i know you're eye
contact
i know
it's adorable we are
we are hunted we're a team that was
really amazing can i just say we [ __ ]
up this should have been the sleepover
episode
stop
no yeah of course every episode should
be a sleepover we wake up like all of
our sleeping bags have weird fingering
holes
i just like george got these [ __ ]
lesbian sleeping bags for us
who imagine sleeping bags with holes
so when you two fingers though not for
one dick yeah yes oh yeah so when you
did come out of like so i told my mom
and i was like i have something really
upsetting she's like melissa's my girl
she's like honey
i obviously every time she left you
would be sobbing like
a friend i was like
who is this
you don't do that when a friend leaves
the house
sobbing uncontrollably i do it when i
know someone's coming over
[Laughter]
do you know she's got a and she loves to
eat
bibles no bible eater
oh god
i love it look i have such a like
what does he say she goes so far up my
all of my cracks
are in your lungs
i'm literally choking on jeans she
always knows the skin i love your legs
annie
these are sleepovers yeah your legs oh
my god like you have good legs how the
[ __ ] have you been hiding this from us
all this time yeah there's some you know
i got my mom's dimples in my face and my
legs so i sometimes i
i get shy
i don't want you guys to see how cute
they are like these cute little dimples
they're smiling
shirley temple
well good thing i got some i got a
cheese tape for you wait did you go to
the desert
i did go to the desert doug stanhope
didn't show up but they brought a
they brought up cut out who'd you go to
the desert with it was with like okay so
doug stanhope and his crew always go to
the desert every year
and um
he every year i've gone doug stand up
has not gone
and i'm always like oh because i've
never met him before so i'm always like
excited to meet him and this year he had
talked about it on rogan where he was
like oh and he let everyone last time i
really wanted to meet her and i was
excited so i was like i dm'd him i was
like i cancelled my weekend i'm coming
he's like i'm down
and then like you know thursday i was
like you're not bailing are you and
you're like no i'm out i was like oh
[ __ ] he's like see it's gang fest and i
was like oh
what's up but it was fun so what do you
guys do what is this thing we do drugs
we do like acid yeah do you all stay in
a house together there's different
cabins and stuff it's really nice some
people camp
is it were there other comics there yeah
it was andy andrus um
chad shack it's all like guys who
have like toured with stan hope so uh
brett erickson um it was really fun
though it was really cool
came uh i did molly
uh mushrooms
what's the ketamine together just all
together and then uh yeah you mix them
yeah uh we tried to take fentanyl strips
and everything yeah
wait what so just for fentanyl yeah you
have to everything everything is lazy
with it that's so smart
i know i can't go i'm not kidding i
don't do enough drugs to then be the
person that the advisors face but you
just don't know what's laced with
anything even a molly could have been
you know no we tested it at all yeah can
i ask a really naive potentially
question it's probably not naive by the
way
why is fentanyl should like so what we
know is like it kills people is it is it
going in drugs showing up randomly in
drugs on purpose because you're trying
to kill people yeah they're trying to
cut it in there no not trying to try not
to chill
seem
like better i i don't know the reason
why they're cutting it i don't really do
drugs i just have these like i don't
know why they cut coke with it because
it coke is an upper and that's a downer
i don't know but i think it makes they
want you to want more maybe but that
isn't how you [ __ ] overdose i just
thought it was trying to cut costs for
some reason molly i do that too
well it looks like my question wasn't
that nice because nobody knows the
answer yeah i think i don't want to brag
but i did call that it wasn't being high
it takes such a tiny amount to go out on
fentanyl it's so bad i know it's really
really terrific okay annie and then what
was the feeling like coming out of the
drug cloud like was it so good did you
have revelations i had a good time well
it wasn't like i i had done san pedro uh
with my shaman up in yosemite
that's right i've never done this type
of talk with you before i do you think
i'm phased by it i just i'm ready to
come out today she has two shamans i'm
coming out to you as a shy
i'm a sham mahali
yeah i'm interested in this [ __ ] i want
to hear about the shaman stuff i'll tell
you something i'm not interested
i think it's insane
i think it's completely insane wait so
you drove up with your shaman to the
mountain i went without him i met him
there oh you met him yeah
what do you do with him
i mean i wish we were having a sexual
relationship i have a good question he's
gay though he doesn't he's not into me
oh
but is he looking like he's cute though
he's so handsome i've crushed on gay
boys he's beautiful he's gorgeous he's
like a he's just a wonderful sweet angel
of man have either one of you ever
been had feelings for a woman not
feelings i've had sex with women but not
not i don't want to be in a relationship
with them
i just said it to see what
yeah i think i feel like all girls just
sort of like were allowed that right or
compare i don't know i've always just
been i would love if boys had a little
they had to just like suck a dick in
college oh i find it hot that bobby
oh my god i understand that completely
yeah
i think it's hot when men have been
i i find it attractive i just kind of
feel like somebody who's i feel like
they're probably really sexually open i
totally agree they'd be more fun in the
bedroom yeah why does your voice get so
sultry
that's my voice i didn't do it on
purpose i swear okay
did it sound soldier okay you've had
threesomes
yeah so you like to talk i don't want to
make myself sound banged out here but it
was two guys
oh that's hot to me
that's hot to me uh
done if you know what i mean see i've
never had sex with a guy and a woman
i've had sex with two women
that's fun yeah no i was so bored i was
in a hotel with two beds and i got up
and went to the other bed and watched
was that convenient there was too many
tits in vagina i was so confused yeah
that's how i felt i was in a
relationship with two men and we lived
together for too many tears and um i
feel the same way after a while like the
sexual perks didn't
make up for the emotional like two
people to to kind of answer to it was
it was lovely for what it was but it
wasn't sustainable well then i got in
trouble after she's like you why did you
have to go down on her i'm like uh well
i didn't know there were rules like you
should have [ __ ] told me what i was
allowed to be invisible are you i know
what are you talking about you were the
one that suggested this and then i got
in trouble
i know you were the one i was talking
about
those boundaries that were never stated
they're like
what did i do
wait so he had a problem with you going
down on her she oh she i agree two women
she can't compute it she can't she loves
the [ __ ] so much
she just adds a cocked every story
tell her story schlatter [ __ ]
seven so funny and not hungry so one of
them
so one of them was your girlfriend and
the other one was not a serious
relationship therefore she was jealous
that you went down on the other girl
right well we were in a club and she
said let's you know we were dancing with
another woman she was a lesbo club yeah
and she said let's sew everyone what's
the music in the lesbian club the music
goes on
no i'm joking i don't know you imagine
yeah that actually would be fun though
annie my skin i have a glow
i don't always have a glow but since
since apostrophe i think the glow is
coming you're growing you're glowing
your feet look good are you putting it
on your ankles
i'm putting it everywhere let me tell
you something i
obviously like we wear makeup for the
show why not but like i have a lot of
skin issues i've been dealing with my
whole life um including like melasma as
i've gotten older and had like hormonal
changes i've had like the darkening of
some spots in my face always near the
mustache huh always my t-zone i have um
eczema i also break out not only on my
face but certain parts of my body this
is where apostrophe has been an absolute
lifesaver because i get to have
basically a dermatologist that i can be
in contact with without ever having to
step into a doctor's office all you have
to do is simply fill out apostrophe's
online quiz about your skin goals and
medical history then snap a few selfies
and your dermatologist will create your
custom customized treatment plan
apostrophe is a prescription skin care
company that offers science-backed oral
and topical medications that are
clinically proven to help clear acne and
apostrophe connects you with a
board-certified dermatologist who will
create a personalized treatment plan
that is
perfectly tailored to your unique skin
it treats acne and they can also help
you hit your other skin care goals like
reducing redness wrinkles and even dark
spots and i really like when i receive
the package they kind of like
personalize it they put little cute
stickers and above all else i hate going
to the pharmacy to pick up any medicine
it's so overwhelming too to just like
know what to get and everything it's
just yes so i love that it just comes to
your door it's mailed to you it's so
convenient um we have a special deal for
our audience save 15 off your first
visit with an apostrophe provider at
apostrophe.com
tuesday when you use our code tuesday
this code is only available to our
listeners to get started go to
apostrophe.com tuesday and click begin
visit then use our code tuesday at sign
up and you'll get your first visit for
only five dollars
that's a-p-o-s-t-r-o-p-h-e
dot com slash tuesday and use the code
tuesday to get your dermatologist
crafted treatment plan for just five
dollars and we thank you apostrophe for
sponsoring this podcast today's episode
is sponsored by our friends at manscape
the leaders and men's below the waist
grooming
you guys it's back to school time and we
want to make sure your man our men
are packing the essentials to have his
best year yet the manscaped fourth
generation performance package is just
that listen todd and i share everything
okay hey you think i'm gonna stop i'm
gonna you think i'm gonna use this
toothbrush and then not use his ball
trimmer excuse me
this package includes a brand new
lawnmower 4.0
and will give him the confidence to do
anything you desire
send him
send him to smooth balls university to
learn a thing or two annie i like smooth
balls i don't mind hair i just need to
know that there's effort involved and
that you cared
enough
that my face was going near it
and that you got yourself a manscape
and escaped the hell out of your mouth
so guys why don't you have a little fun
with it maybe my initials
what are your initials they're afl and
if you want to flip it and just say make
it out why not that's fun
the lawnmower 4.0 also has a 7000 rpm
motor a new multi-function on and off
switch that can engage a travel lock
and gives them the ability to turn the 4
led spotlight
which is really important when needed
for more precise shave
did i mention
this trimmer is waterproof annie so you
can use it in the shower i know on todd
i know and i need is a it's a
it's a dark crevice in there
with my half asian man you're going to
need you're going to need the light i
need the light seal the deal with
manscapes liquid formulations before
heading out with your mans he can use
the crop preserver ball deodorant to
keep him going in the house and just
thank you manscape because it is like
the genre of product that hasn't existed
in the past it's just been a powder it's
like oh that's forming a spicy paste
thank you
get 20 off plus free shipping with a
code trash at manscape.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with a code trash at
manscape.com this year have your man
graduate with a degree in clean balls
from landscape
[Music]
so we brought she's like why don't we
hook up with this girl so we went back
to you know our apartment with her
and it was her idea but then we all
started fooling around and i did
something she was testing you she was
like let's bring this well it's such a
woman thing sorry
i know we got to be it's like jesus
christ this was your idea the invisible
back and now i'm in trouble yeah for
doing something like let's go over the
rules why don't we all sit and talk
about what's okay and what's not it's
like you know it's so [ __ ] ridiculous
i think that there's definitely some
gymnastics well
i will say this um
that happens with men too because again
i've been with two men and one was
always upset
depending on how much um
possession was that how much hold they
had on the [ __ ] you so you had to do
this like kind of like almost [ __ ]
have a timer on because you know did
they fool around with each other never
no just me
oh my god so that part was nice but they
played her like a flu oh my god they
played her like not to sound gang banged
out
i don't want to sound but i was getting
banged out done gotten but uh
there are usually multiple guys were
they both hot they were both really hot
oh my god
yeah one was a math teacher oh that's
hot why is that so hot
do you like math
i like i don't hate math i don't i'm not
like i hate math all the time some
people hate what's so funny to me what i
don't like hate math that's right
who feels like i'm gay
why i'm a lesbian i don't hate i don't
hate math but i love [ __ ]
dave has like a little like camera in
this poodle
he's gonna be real pissed by the time
you get home look look you better keep
[ __ ] that car up so he feels needed
oh my god he did not help me at all
he was so unhelpful he was probably
happy because doesn't he [ __ ] his car a
lot he was probably happy yeah and he
called he's like why is your why did you
drive your car down the stairs i'm
golfing like and then he's just laughing
i'm like okay trump like george is
george
the other man in my life another man i
annoy in my life wait how did this story
end
how did the george came outside and then
a guy george was like okay basically
once george came outside i mentally
checked out i was like this is george's
problem now
and
george was like trying to jack find like
the right tools and [ __ ]
oh that's so embarrassing and this guy
is gonna take it it took like 45 he's
like oh my i ca i know the algorithm of
youtube but
what do you do to jack a car up
he
and this guy was walking past and was
like do you guys need a big jack i mean
he saw that blonde man just searching
and searching and he said let me save
these people he thought he was a
foreigner probably doesn't george look
like he's a tourist
everywhere he goes even in the midwest
he is tourist energy that's so bad sir
do you need me to take a picture of you
oh no you want me to help with the car
okay
so this guy just came jacked it up and
they put like boulders i don't know what
they did
it's so good it was like a chicken
a chain gun walked by you just said
boulders
she doesn't
i don't know what they did but
they figured it out and i was on my way
to get my sweet green salad like it was
just perfect this is a good sweet green
salad but i feel like bobby was like
bobby came outside and
santino was like laughing i feel like
bobby was like angry at me or did he was
jealous that he's the one that usually
crashes yes that's exactly it are you
serious he's usually the guy i mean he's
left his
do you not know his um del taco story
about how his car flipped over a couple
times on the freeway
and then have a dell taco so i feel like
yours is a little different
[Laughter]
she was flipping him up
i'm kidding everybody bye-bye this is my
friend
so he flips his car a couple times in
the freeway and he crawls out and he's
like oh i'm fine there's a del taco
right there he walks in a del taco comes
back goes back to his flipped over car
now there's cops and paramedics and
they're like sir stand back there's a
dead body in there
and he's eating his del taco he goes
that's me
that's me do you get a dui if you are uh
not dui but when you leave the scene of
a crime what's it called hit and run a
hit and run on yourself
i feel like you can
if you go into the report taco
what i swear i really picked up on a
weird energy from both he did this
usually bobby embellishes every single
story nothing is true out of his mouth
right so when he calls me he's like
i was like what happened he's like call
me back 9-1-1 i'm like what happened
he's like esther drove down some stairs
i was like that's that's an embellished
story he told you 9-1-1 over that he
didn't even because [ __ ] was he laughing
this is my impression he walks out
looked over and he's just like
here this is making it look like you did
this on purpose for attention
give it to you
what was his take on i've been dying
tonight he doesn't have a take on it
it's more like it's on brand for you
okay yeah yeah
how often it's also it's on brand for
him he does it often
am i coming for bobby's place i think so
i think you're trying to steal his
essence i think that's the feeling you
got i think
and he's here to guide you into
realizing that every [ __ ] up is
literally the best part
because like you know what i mean
yeah that could do serious i gotta go
oh my god hold on oh wow i love those
shorts on yoni
are those like things from the desert in
there yeah
i got some beer
some
sand crabs
here's what's gonna disappoint you
because i know you wanted to go to
hawaii right yeah all the strip clubs
there because i tried every day that i
was there all the strip clubs they
closed at midnight
and there's plexiglass around the girls
and it really kind of zapped the
it zapped the joy
i did do they use the plexiglass to like
push their [ __ ] up against it i don't
know everybody just seemed a little sad
to be dancing use your space you know
what i mean like mush wouldn't you want
that wait mush against
yeah that would be hard you're right i
did try to be phone friends with you for
a while it only didn't i called you
twice and we talked and i it just didn't
keep i didn't but i'll call you i will
talk to you i need to talk to you i will
talk to you i'll talk about pushed up
[ __ ] against glass
do you remember what we talked about the
whole night no
[Music]
is it about a person no were just
talking about louie we were just like oh
oh i don't know we were just louis
sympathizers for hours we were just like
we were like come on we've masturbated
in front of openmakers
for hours
we were just like we've totally done
that and then i was like maybe we
shouldn't talk about it publicly
the views express
podcasts
you guys are all so naturally funny i
love being on podcasts like this because
sometimes i'm like
uh you left college and you decided
that is where did you feel that comedy
was the route for you oh god if someone
asked me that again when i was molested
in fact i literally
they'll ask you questions like um
so they'll say to me like you know you
quit drinking the first time at 12 what
was that about i'm like dude what
do you want
if i was drinking at 12 i think
it was one of three things a dick or one
of the balls
how'd you get a comedy
severe trauma i don't know severe
my father called me a fat gun what do
you want
mine was that really your nickname i was
selfish [ __ ] oh i was fat guys i was
selfish man
i was
this is a great duo for the stage
what was your nickname fat gun what was
your selfish gun
i wish i had
a resting my dad called me a [ __ ] face
you tell daddy was mean
so nice now it's so weird i know that is
weird it's so nice it's so weird how
they switch well my dad's kind of like a
queen a little bit about things is your
dad still alive
my dad was amazing he my dad gave me my
my sense of humor
he was the funniest person i've ever
known
it's really okay anyway
it's so rude to say in front of us
i thought we were the funniest people
you've ever met
i feel the same way too yeah and by the
way i agree with every everyone i meet
who thinks their dad's the funniest
their dads are the funniest thing yeah
right he was really i mean i didn't
laugh harder than anyone in my life you
should feel like that you should meet
this dad your dad really we should have
a dad episode with both of our dads
because i think you should do that
that would be really interesting my dad
like i i feel like he doesn't bring it
on camera the way my mom can but you got
to just keep the camera yeah that's true
the real them comes out i brought my
parents on girl code once they came on
girl code they all they wanted to be on
tv my dad's i was like do they have old
man code
i'd be like and i we did like a joke
once i was like filming him i was like
i'll send this to the producers and i go
dad um what's hard about being old and
he's like my dick he goes not my dick
and you could hear my niece in the
background playing
it's just like the war i'm like dad he's
just so
he goes there
he's dirty your dad's not that dirty no
i don't tolerate that annie i'm going to
stop you because you're going to be
pissed at me if i don't tell you but
this lashes it's so annoying i had to
put them on while i was driving though
yeah i wasn't like so nice driving
house isn't that funny that you just
told her about her lash like i have not
once did your makeup on i look gorgeous
yeah oh please that's so good
everyone who's trying to bang you so
oh you do have like big dick energy yeah
yeah yeah you could trick a [ __ ] you
could trick a straight yeah have you
tricked any straighties before i've been
dressed
obviously lesbians are like they can
plant some seeds in you though i didn't
i didn't it's not like i tricked a
stranger
but i've been with straight girls but
yeah
there's just there's so many young girls
that are like i'm bi it's like no you're
not you're like all right that's what i
get annoyed with that's why i don't
seriously okay
i'm just never as the representative let
me hear let me hear you i just get i as
someone who is has an
unclear sexual identity i get like
irritated when there's all like growing
up all the people in college are like
where bi and it's like
no you're not like you're not you're
you're just doing it for attention and
like if you were really bi like i don't
think i would know i don't know never
mind no i agree with you completely let
it come the feelings
let it come we hear you wow
the woman is like squirting like a
shower on you annie you like why you
have to make it so explicit right out
the gate wait that's not explicit we've
been about 30 minutes
have you guys been peed on ever
like in the shower i was like
intentionally like in your hair i'm just
gonna have a guy pee on me but it's
actually kind of fun
you think i'd like it
on my face
everything i peed on someone
did they know
when did they wake up no it's my
grandmother [ __ ] outside
i can't i said breakfast [ __ ]
nanny wake up
yeah but the guy who peed on me
was so nice afterwards like he likes so
between my toes he like shampooed my
hair oh that's the fetish it's not even
the peeing it's that part but that
part's hot like that's the extreme and
then getting so much like look tender
loving care
should we go to a
so you like when a guy is very um like
dominating with you or do you like to
also dominate well i've always been
[Laughter]
i've always been super dominant
so i've recently turned a corner into
wanting to just be completely submissive
and trying it out and it turns out that
might be more my lane these days this is
the planting seeds lesbian stands by the
way
she leans back the seeds are flying from
her eyes into your mind right now
jess i love to be just
tears coming down
that's the part when i get the most
excited when the woman's like
when there's like black tears from the
makeup that's when i come
i have to wait till that part when she
looks like she's going to die
i know that they're all purple because
my mom wasn't around i that's why i
think i like when a woman looks like
she's going to die because i have anger
issues your mom wasn't around because
you were a fat gun
[Laughter]
i love you so much no
she didn't want to be around no because
she was a therapist helping everyone
else at the time when i was younger
yeah when i was younger now i could also
be no she's been around she's been
around
your mom might have liked you better no
my mom's older mom i'm sorry
no she's been around since for years and
years and years but when i was much when
i was very young she was helping
everyone she was like a seminar leader
big
therapist what
she worked she did like s seminars you
know what that is oh my parents are
obsessed with oh we have to talk
about the forum
my mom too we have money i went did you
i did s at eight years old i did i did i
was 19 when i did limited i did it at 21
in the world trade center yeah world
champion yeah landmark my whole family's
done like why did you call it s
um because that's what i used to be in
no i was born before the 21 in the world
i was trying to make it that you were in
the towers doing landmark as they were
following
it was a stretch i'll give you i'm an
[ __ ] but that's okay
they're like bring more people like oh
okay
why
no one gets what you just said but
that's so funny
it's fine it's all about getting people
to do it we never made you bring any
people if they just stopped it would be
difficult
i would be
tell your friends you need to bring
people to the seminars that's what made
me crazy
that makes it then sound like a pyramid
yeah it's not even just you know
anyone you've ever had an issue with so
i'm calling up people that like [ __ ]
me over i'm like hey and i'm giving them
like this i know i called the guy that
raped me i was like can you come up with
something i literally almost called the
teacher that molested me i literally was
like i called like one of the teachers
what did they tell you to do to just
make amends no there's a whole like i
can't remember the criteria like what's
the like the language it's like it's
like i did x
it's you which which creates something
it's your reaction it's yours and that's
a way to hold you accountable
yes but you're held to too much
accountability meaning like it's like
you could be assaulted and then if you
keep talking about it it's your racket
like you just have to get over it and
it's crazy parts of it make a lot of
sense
it like had a huge impact on me i was
like i should get over it yeah you just
landmarked me in the way i i
i just [ __ ] land march
let's start our own landmark yeah
we should
we'll call it um
fat cut and self
have a seminar you two are crazy yes
you two
i want to know wait that's a big bond to
have with someone to both be in landmark
though because i imagine growing up with
this
i am so [ __ ]
let's do landmark form weekends i would
love to show you guys you guys should i
would love to i should do it again my
whole resistance is my mother it'll
change your life you'd be so grossed out
at the end with the sales pitch it's
like the sales sales pitch is so and
they never stop and they call you all
the time did you used to get the
landmark calls i can't [ __ ] kill you
kill your family
i'll kill you
[ __ ] you you're [ __ ] wrestling
your ass
i hate them it's like so annoying
it didn't i was so engaged i would be 13
and they'd be like hi this is joyce from
landmark working for free by the way
joyce is making that one penny yeah
my mom may not want penny and they'd be
like
then we'd like you to come to our
seminar i'm like um i'm i'm fisting
myself watching the love sorry i'm so
i'm gonna have to
wait to love though
okay we're all gonna go to landmark
together next time we it's a great thing
why are you triggered by this i'm not
triggered i have i do okay i have fomo i
feel left out but i i am you're always
there i want you dragging your ass there
no because you did that funny voice and
i'm very curious is that like because
you're very good at that and i want to
know about this prank album because i
want to hear it oh you're getting into
it okay yeah she's very good you got a
professional baby i want to know what's
up with this what is it tell us like so
during during covid um
so rachel feinstein and i have been
doing stuff together for many many many
years is she that she's so she's the
comedian
yeah
right
she is so funny she's got the hotter she
had a kid and it's starting to [ __ ]
piss me because she's got a great go
together my body will be better yeah
and she makes me laugh so hard i can't
take it
anyway so we've been so funny yeah so
we've been
making silly you know videos together
for years and we have a very similar
life we grew up jewish moms are
therapists just very similar upbringing
and we've always done these voices so
during culver we were both depressed
down of course you know my dad passed
away a month into covid
from cancer from cancer and she was at
least he wasn't happy
good for him
at least i didn't catch it from him yeah
and um and she you know was giving birth
you know pregnant during cove that was
intense and her husband's a hot
firefighter hot firefighter so awesome
she literally had a dream coming through
here got his body's hair she really just
did the whole thing yeah i love the blue
collar she did the whole thing but he's
like what about a woman
and she just starts like laying bricks
[Laughter]
and he's you know first responder it's
just hard time we were both
downs we were like let's make prank
calls so we recorded these prank calls
from home and and my manager jim serpeco
and virtual comedy network recorded them
and we just made all these calls for
months from home from our homes and we
we tortured businesses like we called a
massage parlor as two old jewish women
were like we'd like a socially distanced
massage
the woman's like what are you talking
about i'm like does anyone there have
long arms
[Laughter]
we just called a sex shop like it's too
like you know oh my god we want sex toys
like our boyfriends want us to use sex
toys on each other like we just
called all these places and we made this
album called call girls and um you know
it's like women haven't done it we want
to we're going to do another one and
have other comics on to you guys should
come on i've been here before i've been
here before guys hey i'm doing a
documentary about female comedians can't
wait to have you on it never hear from
her andy that wasn't my choice i can't
wait that was not like the main thing it
was not no it's not everything to say
you know how you're like there's others
the powers
that's not it you know what happens in
hollywood
things are cast oh my god wow you made
it racial no it's not really a girl not
no no it's old young it's from people
from different places
you know straight seriously it's a lot
of things do they know about that i was
molested
yeah she's the diddled queen it wasn't
and listen but i was saying she was
never i allowed her about myself
well she's been she's had some well
whatever i'm fine it's not well the
massage parlor the other day
just don't know just there's the one
massage creepy massage it's like well
creepy massage is pretty intense they
will get inside you let's just say those
aren't social distances and they do have
long arms i do want to say
my one of the heart the hardest i ever
laugh is like thinking about being with
my friends and doing prank calls
together and the thought that i can just
listen to a bunch of them like i'm
really excited
they're so funny esther they they real i
mean i'm serious they're re i've played
like did you film them too or yeah we
filmed we filmed them i knew a lot of
them are filming costumes and stuff no
we didn't wear costumes but um you know
we we did like they're just so funny we
called um a dc hotel during like right
after the insurrection
and we said that we left items in the
lobby
and and we kept listing more and more
things we left in the lobby and it's
just so [ __ ] they're great how long
do they
tell stand
um
some of them stay on forever because
they're nice right it's not the thing it
depends what the characters are it
depends like when you know when i'm like
a kid like hi i want a cake you know
like a quality bakery and they'll stay
on forever with a kid oh but if you call
is like a guy it's not i called a
vitamin shop asking for as a fat person
asking for something i want some
supplements
and the guy's like all right uh i can
help you out and then like during the
call i'm like can i get some roast beef
i like it steadily sliced
[Laughter]
my best memories are of being in the
phone's room at the comedy store and
with aristotle who literally just got
cast on snl and i would just be like i
would because he's so good at voices i
would like he is good i would just like
do this do this and he would just do it
for me and i would just sit and laugh
like and i've been craving that i'm so
excited about oh yeah thank you they're
great i'm so it's so much fun for me and
it's like it's so silly and i feel like
people need silly now on that note um
jess when um
we're gonna need you and start each of
these we do a banana break
on every show we re-up on the potassium
um these are so
all right
damn
annie i was banana-shamed in hawaii it
turns out i've been opening oh i'm not
opening them like the monkeys show me
so apparently i don't know if this will
because it's not fully ripe because i
don't know which yeah the [ __ ] don't
know how to choose a banana who broke
this up but apparently you're supposed
to squeeze the tip i'm not doing that
it's like putting on
and it pops open
and it's much easier
and then you have the nub in your yeah
so you don't go on the nub at all you
just
squeeze the tip you know i kind of like
that because when i sometimes when i do
the nub it gets like bruised yes i don't
like bruises if it doesn't like snap
immediately no
look
oh my gosh
oh no
that's the best yet huh
i like bananas like this i don't like
when they're too right i agree
no like when they shoot out so i agree
with everything she says so are we doing
hawaii
i
all you have to do is tell me when and
where
where is white
yeah
i just said hawaii i feel bad that like
i'm basically just putting it on you to
plan me a vacation which is what's
happening when are you getting married
never
not after this she sweated him for years
about being engaged and that's all she
wants i think she wanted the uh comfort
and control of would he be upset if
you're with a lady yes
listen
together
more upset than if i was with a man i
think really yes genuinely yes that's
interesting i know i've no i never
thought i would hear that from someone
but yeah because i think he's really
like
are you gay like yes
we all ask you that a lot
your parents your friends your loved
ones your doctor your parents your dogs
your therapist
god
george you're giving me some strong
lesbian vibes you're a jazz beam oh
jewish lisbon
i think um good like strong lesbian
energy jess would you say you do
yeah
yeah i do get hit on by um really
gorgeous
yeah coco
seriously i will say disproportionately
i think more women hit on me than men
because i have like tomboy energy okay
no to men you're going to be too
intimidating you think yes you're too
hot you're too hot you have to be gay we
decided you're going to get hit on they
always sit on my lap asking for cocaine
sit on your shoulders yeah
i want to wrap my legs right around
those yeah i think it's all about you
sometimes and i noticed this since we
started doing this podcast together like
sometimes i'll like
want
not to like let you hang up like i just
want to keep you like maybe like let's
say like we egg like with this product i
understand what you're saying i want to
linger with you and because it's i get
it
i wanted to start talking to you on the
phone you soothed me she's fun she's a
good face timer yeah i am annie and i
facetime i think the first time she
called me
we talked for like five hours
with you though because you're too
attractive
i do want to point out she did say she
could totally talk to me
i want to be clear i just want to be
clear that this is platonic i don't want
anyone to think there's anything going
on here okay no harry
i'll tell you why people nice i'm being
serious because i already feel close to
you i mean i'm not saying that to be
funny i feel close to you i absolutely
love you i'm so excited you're here i do
feel close to you already so it's
already there but you're hot
hot hot beyond hot mm-hmm her i can't
start a whole thing child model hot as
molested um well this has been
a lot of this has been a lot of things
dude you guys are so funny stop this if
anyone's listening to this
you need to tell everyone to listen to
them
watch it this is so funny well of course
watch it
don't listen i mean you got to watch
this this is amazing obviously i mean
we've one of these these are
sexually harassment you're amazing i
don't give a [ __ ] i've sexually harassed
you guys too the bananas sitting in my
throat
i'm telling you i don't chew well
kalila could be sitting on your throat
stop
it will be there
stop it come to me naughty
cute new outfit thank you she keeps
getting new outfits and not giving us
any i will i will okay no we have to
wrap this up this has been this has been
many many things she's turned into such
a little hot girl look at her i'm hot
yes you're so you can you are
you're adorable you're like a little
famous girl you're a little famous la
girl we gotta get you rid of this oh my
god she just went in for a kiss i know
but i know her well i don't want it i
think you don't want it i don't know if
the tongue scraper was used
[Laughter]
i used to date a guy who would scrape my
tongue before he kissed me just so you
that is sweet for you though
did you were you okay with that it's
like shaving your [ __ ] it was like
shaving your tongue
but it would i don't it didn't last long
that's what i said i was like look he's
not going to be down for you sexually if
he's like having hang ups that's a gay
man thing honestly those are the guys
that are like i think closeted gay who
are like i worry about smell it's like
yeah like when you're really into
something i agree with you you want to
like [ __ ] smell like [ __ ] i need a
dick smell like a dick it's all good
it's fine it's just what does a dick
smell like it depends meg or no
okay we're done today
we are it's hard to tell what's my
breath
she looked at the characters
oh my god i'm gonna kill myself thank
you same let's go did you just say that
it smells like the back of my throat
and with every guy that's listening to
every guy and disgusting lesbian
that's vile like me
is dying over what she just said i know
and so are the girls that are learning
from her
no they're going like this you can't be
a man and hear what she just said and
not being rock hard right now
it's there's men in this room are you
here rock hard should that be in the
name of our podcast we keep wanting to
rename our podcast well i told her we
did we not almost name it skull [ __ ]
yeah should name it right now
i don't remember names if i could just
be with a woman's head
that doesn't speak let me say something
publicly right now
i would like to be with just a skull
that's your what was the what was the
shakespeare
no i don't want her to talk though yeah
i just want her to taste dick
okay
um by the way i also have four daughters
and i went for a master's in social work
all right
[Laughter]
um you guys everyone needs to listen to
jessica kirsten's comedy album for prank
calls i'm i'm doing i know there's a lot
going on i'm flustered but where can we
hear more of you for real like no that's
all over itunes everything pandora of
course it's called call girls with
rachel feinstein and
i have a website jessicacarson.com which
has all my yeah i've been touring a lot
let's go on the road and i have a
podcast disgusting hawk where i dress up
as
all these different characters and
interview comics which i i'm it's it's
really funny i do an old jewish woman a
dick guy a sex therapist i just did tom
sagar and the scholar brothers at moon
tower comedy festival oh at the same
time i'm doing it at skankfest annie do
it it's gangfest okay i'm done i'm
interviewing you
doug i'm gonna meet well there was this
cardboard cut out and i wish i brought
it with me to have here it was so
literal i'm going to interview annie at
skankfest as one of my characters it's
called disgusting can i tell you
something i like about you more than the
other character people that i know yeah
you actually uh like being yourself too
i feel like the character people are a
lot of times are hiding their true
selves oh no darkness no and in them in
my podcast i do a long thing as myself
in the podcast too i just do some
character stuff it's like the marin
thing where everyone skips over when
he's talking to go to the interview
let's get to the goods all right marin
you're still mad at your mom and dad all
right well the character stuff i do is
pretty dark you guys should check it out
really dark
deep dive yeah it's on youtube it's
great all right everybody like and
subscribe for more we'll see you later
bye everyone bye guys bye guys see you
next week
[Music]
you